[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campell joined
by the Jade warshaw this hour and we're
taking your calls at
8825 5225 ring us up we'll talk about
whatever's going on with your life and
your money and Jade it was a fun week
last week pre-launching my new book
Breaking Free from broke thank you to
the thousands who uh have already pre
purchased to get all the bonus items you
get audiobook ebook uh access to my new
talk 3 months of every dollar there's so
much in there I forget how much that's a
lot look there's no reason that you
shouldn't pre-order this book today with
$100 in free bonus items like it's a
win-win this is like Total Money
Makeover meets Complete Guide to Money
meets the print and borrowed future
meets my YouTube channel a lot of
information it's eye opening it's
motivating a lot of humor empathy snark
and research so you're going to love it
I guarantee it there you go go check it
out ramsy solutions.com store and get
your copy all right let's go to lyia out
in St Paul Minnesota what's going on
Lydia hey thanks for taking my call sure
how can we
help so I want some advice on a one-year
game plan um we have some credit card
debts it's about
9,000 my husband and I are moving so he
can go back to school and he won't bring
in some income at least during the
school year so I want we want to figure
out how can we eliminate most of this
credit card day I do have a little bit
of student loans as well um in the next
year how are you paying for
school so it's actually Seminary and um
the way it works we're Orthodox the way
it works is that we go under our Arch
dasis and so um they will be paying for
all the
seminarians our so no cost to you guys
what about the student loans that you
have now how many how much is that yeah
I have 30k in student loans okay any
other
debt and then credit card debt is 9,000
okay and is he able to work at all
outside of school
um probably during the summer I know
that they have connections for the the
seminarians during is he taking classes
40 hours a week with no time to take a
part-time job on top of that
yeah yep and are you working outside of
the
home um no I work I'm a work from home
mom so we don't worry about child care I
have flexible schedule and I'll be able
to keep my job what were your what will
your income
be right now I'm making
3,000 um but it will probably go up in
the next 6 months probably double
because of
what I'll be able to go full-time ah
okay great and is that your take-home
pay per
month so I'm at
1099 um so I do have to account for
taxes oh boy after after taxes what
would you um estimate it to
be when you get there when you go
fulltime I don't even know yet okay my
guess is you're looking at probably
closer to 2200 take home yeah is that
enough for you guys to
live so Seminary is being Orthodox it's
uh it's literally giving up everything
to go it's not like normal Protestant
Seminary it's truly giving up everything
and so they not they're not covering
your housing or anything right they have
married housing so you're not needing to
pay rent or anything figure out we will
but where we're going it's a lot cheaper
than where we are now when does that
start in a
year okay so let me just make sure I get
a whole idea of this he doesn't start
this for one year so you're wanting to
pay off as much debt as possible so that
when you get to this Seminary time you
have less
debt yeah and then how long does
Seminary last three years okay and what
does he make
now uh not much what's he doing what I
make everything that he possibly can he
graduated a year ago from his
undergraduate and um it's been very hard
for him to find something that well what
was his under undergrad
in history oh
boy yeah so what was he doing teaching
going no no no we thought about waiting
about 5 years so that way he could find
some work but it has been very very hard
and so one day we were like maybe we
should just go earlier and so we've
spoken with a lot of people and they
said before you have more kids before
you have to you know think about other
things educating your kids and all that
maybe go look I disagree I'm I'm gonna
be honest with you I think I disagree I
think that um you guys have a mess that
needs to be cleaned up almost $40,000 of
debt
and you guys have not figured out how to
make an income as a couple yet and I
think that you need to figure that out
for a couple of reasons a when you enter
life as an adult and you get your big
girl and big boy job and you're like you
know what okay I've established my value
in the market as far as what people will
pay me to do a job there's a certain
level of confidence that comes along
with that and I think going from that
into Seminary is going to make you guys
feel far more confident going forward as
opposed to it kind of being being like
well he wasn't able to get a job let's
just go ahead and try Seminary and then
it puts you up against this clock of
okay we have one year and then cuz what
happens if you don't pay off the debt in
a year cuz on $2,200 a month that's
going to be very
difficult M and so that's I mean you
called us that's my two cents I I
understand you said you have a lot of
other folks giving you some other advice
but if it were me there doesn't seem to
be any reason for him to quickly go into
a season of not making income for three
years that's just me yeah what is the
purpose of him going to Seminary where
did this come from to become a priest
but where where and why and when did
this all happen that he feels called to
this uh the first day I met him I knew
that he was going to pursue
Seminary okay and so we've always had
that on our timeline and we got married
in college we've
lived you know we've lived in his
parents house we've been able to be in
our own place for a year I mean we've
lived incredibly frugally and humbly um
trying to get through school and being
married and also bringing a baby in our
first year marriage so we're used to the
lifestyle um of living pretty humbly I
just don't want the next three years of
your life to be living hell in stress
because there's not enough income coming
in he's trying to get through school
he's feeling the pinch you're trying to
take on the burden of running this
household financially and physically and
that's going to take a toll on the
marriage so as as anything you can do to
pay off this debt before you start
Seminary is going to set you up for
Success cuz the truth is dreams take
sacrifice and so if he really wants this
dream he has this dream of being a
priest he better work 80 hours a week
for the next year if he's serious about
this dream and can I ask a question what
does a priest make do like what what
type of salary or is there a
salary it depends um it depends on what
the parish that you're assigned to well
what would you expect had to
guess I would I don't know really don't
know the number I really want you guys I
really want you guys to research this
further before you decide that in the
next 3 to 4 years you're not going to
have an
income absolutely and uh we we've got to
do some homework here before we take
this next step but I'm doing everything
I can I'm pausing this dream until we
get this debt paid off and get a good
Financial footing under us thanks for
the call Lydia this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data net Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netweek gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us netw
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw this
hour the number to call is
5225 well Jade about 4,000 people sent
me this article our team was buzzing
about it this was big news last week
here's the headline into it to close
mint and migrate users to Credit Karma
budgeting app mint will be killed off on
the 1st of January with users invited to
migrate their data to Credit Karma ooh
how inviting that sounds I never would
give me your data that's what it feels
like gross last year the mint team was
integrated into Credit Karma as into it
looks to combine the forers money
management products with the latter's
technology and product ecosystem let me
tell you what their product ecosystem is
by the way it's debt uhhuh that's their
entire business model is luring you into
different loan products credit card
products and debt products so uh don't
fall for it Credit Karma has never been
a budgeting platform ever everyone uses
it to keep up with their credit score
which is a waste of brain calories in my
book help me understand okay so yeah
they they go on to say Credit Karma will
use customer data to do things like
suggest people use a different credit
card to maximize their rewards
opportunities or flag when they're about
to be in a cash crunch that's sad yeah
that's not budgeting by the way and so
what they're moving people to is not a
budgeting app at all no that's rough
it's just really a way to monitor how
quickly you're going into debt it ends
with however users will no longer have
the ability to set monthly and category
budgets instead getting a simplified way
quote for you to build awareness of your
spending and track your savings hold up
hold up what does that mean what it
means is that we have a solution for for
these people because this right here is
not a solution at all no so what's the
solution George CU I well we have a
world class budgeting app that does the
one thing you want it to do which is
make a plan for your money ahead of time
by the way not just tracking the
mistakes you made last month and how
much you didn't door Dash that's right
but actually making a plan for your
money and we've got millions of people
that have used every dollar to get that
financial piece get that confidence for
where their money's going and that's the
Crux of our entire plan that's right and
we won't sell their information and we
won't sell you debt that's for sure and
we won't sell them debt and we'll give
them here's what I I'll be honest back
in the day back in 2015 or so I
downloaded mint thinking okay I need a
budget I'll try this one what it wasn't
why I didn't like it is because if
you're trying to get out of debt if
you're trying to save money if you're
trying to build wealth for the very
first time you need education like you
need guidance you need something there
helping you knowing what the next step
is okay I have this option or this
option what should I do and one of the
things I love about every dollar is
there's that guidance built in that's
always kind of pushing you in a
direction it's connected to Ramsay so
it's always teaching you our principles
really so it's it's more than just a
budget it's like a free education you
know what I'm saying oh yeah so for the
4 million mint users if you're listening
to this I want to let you know we
welcome you with open arms over to every
dollar and lucky for you I'm doing a
free training this Friday November 10th
12:30 Eastern Time 11:30 Central Time
showing you how to break the paycheck to
paycheck cycle showing you how to create
margin in your finances using every doll
for an hour we're going to sit there
answer your questions show you how it
works to build your first budget we're
going to make it easy on you just go to
Every doll.com budgeting to sign up for
the webinar it's completely free and uh
you get to hang out with me if that's
something you choose to do like that
there you go another thing going on Jade
is uh in the Ramsey solution store very
exciting we've got some awesome gifts
for Christmas during our $12 sale
including bestselling books like The
Total Money Makeover baby steps
Millionaires and own your past change
your future just bucks each and some of
those questions for humans conversation
cards those are fun I love those fun
gifts 10 bucks right now you can go as
low as so plus we've got the Christmas
edition of questions for humans that's
back and these sold out quick last year
so go check out everything on sale at
the ramsy solutions store just go to
ramsy solutions.com store it's a
One-Stop shop for all your Christmas
shopping love that easy skip the socks
get him a Total Money Makeover book
there you go when you said skip the
stock socks I thought you were talking
about the stockings and I was about to
be like wait oh no we can't skip the
stockings yeah CU these are great
stocking stuffers that's true if the
book fits stuff it there we go all right
let's get to the phones kayn joins us in
Atlanta kayn welcome to the show hey
thank you very much for having me sure
how can we help alrighty so I'm trying
to figure out a way to eliminate um I
have 314,000 in debt um so I'm trying to
figure out ways that I can pretty much
reduce that what kind of debt is
it so I have 28 7,000 in uh home debt
and then 7,000 in credit cards but it's
divided in between two okay and then
have 20 in student loans okay so the
mortgage debt is it just simply your
mortgage or did you take out any sort of
P loock or loan against your mortgage at
all yeah just simply my mortgage okay
awesome um so for the time being can we
just take that 278 and just put it on
the shelf and kind of pretend for a
moment that it doesn't exist because the
way we teach the first amount of debt
that you're going to pay off is just
everything except your mortgage so I
think looking at it like that is going
to make you go ooh okay $27,000 of debt
I can handle that is that fair enough
yeah sounds good awesome um so how
familiar are you with our
teaching not too much I've been starting
to get into it especially now that I've
gotten older I just graduated um last
year and life kind of sped up so now I'm
like all right let me get ahead of the
game before I you know I let a lot of
time
pass so the way we teach is a series of
baby steps and maybe you've heard it
before it's seven baby steps and for all
intents and purposes right now you're on
baby step one now do you happen to have
any money saved
anywhere yeah so I have three separate
retirement accounts and then I in my
bank account I have about 4,000 okay
4,000 in your bank account now is that
for bills or is that money that you're
calling savings savings okay awesome so
what I would do baby step one is to get
$1,000 saved so I would earmark ,000
that as baby step one for you and that
leaves 3,000 left and we would take that
3,000 and we would apply it to your debt
baby step two is paying off all of your
debt except your mortgage and you're
doing that using the debt snowball
method and what that is is we list all
those debts that you have smallest to
largest so in this case probably your
two credit cards are going to be first
and then your student loans if those are
broken into smaller loans you would list
those along with your credit cards in
order to in order of smallest to largest
does that make sense so so we'd pay that
3,000 on whatever the smallest debt is
my guess it's a credit card yeah exactly
is it enough to pay off that credit card
yeah for one of them yes boom that's GNA
feel good it's working already George so
you pay off that first credit card and
then if you have any extra money that
you can throw towards debt you put it on
the next smallest debt and that's what
you're doing month to month and the key
here is you going quickly right so we're
bringing in as much money as possible
what's your income at this
point so it's 101,000 hey let's go there
we go what are you investing right now
you said you've got three retirement
accounts what percentage of your income
are you investing so right now I'm doing
$50 a month and just a Ross that's
through Primerica and then I have a 403b
account for a hospital that I used to
work for I work every once in a while so
usually about a month I'm putting in 35
then they're averaging like a 15th it's
not too much on that one so let's say
$50 a month and then I'm doing 4% of my
actual salary right now in a separate
Roth okay so what if for just a short
time we took that 4% down to zero we
paused all of our investing that's only
100 bucks over there 4% over here but
what that's going to do is add a nice
chunk of change to your monthly income
you can use to throw at the debt
probably you know 300 bucks worth at
least true true and so that's going to
get you out of debt even faster because
I think making a 100 grand you can pay
off 27 very quickly yeah what would it
look like if you lived on 75,000 or
70,000 this year instead of
101 it look a lot prettier that's for
sure it' look like you being debt free
yeah man doing this while you're young
as a new grad is going to be so much
easier than doing it later on in life
when you have other responsibilities and
a spouse or kids and life got expensive
and uh I think that's going to free you
to then get your emergency fund fast 3
to 6 months after you're out of debt
then we'll go back to investing and it's
not going to be a meager 4% we're going
to bump that up to 15% which is going to
be 15 grand a year and then you pop that
into a compound interest calculator and
your eyes will explode over how much
money that will turn into over time then
in baby step six once you got that
dialed in baby step six we can start
paying off the house early by throwing
extra at the principal and you'll get
there man okay sounds good you're going
to be in your early 30s with a paid for
house if you followed this stuff that's
right and not fall for all the traps and
distractions that are out there today
and there's a whole lot of them George
you know about paying off your house in
your have you hit are you in 30s yeah
okay you got a boyishly young face I
wasn't sure thank you I'm somewhere
between 25 and 40 I'll never tell no
it's fun it's a good life living in baby
step 7 I'll tell you that much and it's
possible whether you're 25 or 55 you can
get there these steps work for everyone
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw if
you want to talk about your life and
your money call us at 8825
5225 Eileen is in Portland Oregon Eileen
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi thank you
for taking my call sure um my husband at
58 years old has been diagnosed with
early on S
dementa and you guys talk about
long-term care but I think I can
self-insure okay so I was wondering if
you had any suggestions on how to plan
yeah walk us through some of the numbers
here what's your nest
egg uh 3.0 awesome very and are either
of you still working we both are okay
and what's the household
income uh it ranges from 140 to 160 very
good
wonderful okay and what does the next
few years look like as far far as his
care have you looked into that um not
really um he really needs to change
careers because it's causing more stress
um but we don't know what that looks
like yet with his with his
diagnosis um what does he qualify as far
as long-term care
is concerned since he's already
gotten a
diagnosis what you mean as far as like
asking about the insurance long-term
care insurance uhuh or well I guess my
question is so if he loses his job um he
is a bread winner and he holds all the
insurance um the health insurance so if
he loses that or can't work um then we
have I'm 56 so we would have many years
without insurance until we can get to
Medicare
mhm she'd be covering that out of pocket
for those years which you have the money
to do I you guys have an awesome Nest
Egg what is that invested in um 401K Ira
Roth um and then he has um a um oh I
can't remember what it's called with the
company contribute some to AAG um and
then yeah well kind of it's sort of
pension plan kind of yeah kind of like
3% a year and then I have a couple few
small ones um but I'm self employed so I
can't contribute too much so you
mentioned that he's the bread winner of
the 160 per year what portion of that is
his and what portion is
yours um he's probably between 115 and
125 depending on overtime okay and then
I'm the rest okay that's all gross
that's gross that's not no okay okay so
what we need to cover what we're
thinking about is just not only your
normal um insurance needs health
insurance needs but at certain at a
certain point you're going to want some
sort of care for him um as this
progresses some sort of inhome care
right yeah I'm hoping so yeah but I
don't know how soon I'm just I just have
no idea it was a surprise oh I bet
that's now the issue you may run into is
because he has this pre-existing
condition it may keep you from
qualifying right so that's something
that too you may be out on that I'm glad
you have this Nest EG because if this
happened you guys were broke it would be
a different situation but you might need
you might need to self-insure you might
not qualify for that long-term care I
would still look into it I think it's a
bargain for what you're going to get out
of it um but you guys should be okay
other than you know dealing with this
diagnosis where we don't know what the
next several years of his life looks
like and if he's going to be able to
continue working yeah but it sounds like
you guys have set yourself up to where
it's going to be okay either
way yeah I guess it just doesn't feel
that way I guess you know do you guys
have any debt no zero no house payment
or anything so if you looked at your
household expenses and you looked at
your income could you still cover all
the bills without even touching the nest
EG right
[Music]
now not that probably not no that might
be some good homework for you to to sit
down and use every dollar and we'll gift
you 3 months of that to sit down with
the premium version and go okay let's
look at all of our bills let's look at
our income now let's delete your income
out of this equation and see where that
would leave
us okay also something that would make
me feel better if I found s in your
shoes e I'd probably sit down with my
investment professional and I'd say okay
let's project the next three years what
do we think that our net worth is going
to stand at and what would it take what
could we draw off of our
retirement in order to meet what we what
we pay ourselves now which is around
$140,000 a year and could we comfortably
do so it looks like with the 3 million
net worth that you have if that's what's
in retirement you'd be able to do that
very easily and then if you say okay now
let's just assume that we're we don't
have health coverage like we thought we
were going to have what's that going to
cost us out of pocket and if we add that
again to what we're drawing off of our
Nest Egg and I can just tell you just
quickly running some numbers in my head
you're going to be fine but I think it's
going to make you feel a lot better if
you sit down with your investment
professional if you don't have one you
can find one of our uh smart Vestor pros
and sit down with them and I think
that's going to give you and your
husband a lot of Peace for someone to
track out the numbers with you and show
you on paper what this is going to cost
you how much money you're going to have
in the next 3 to 5 years and that's
going to give you guys um the piece you
need to sleep at night thank you for the
call Eileen hang on the line we're going
to gift you three months of every dollar
premium so you can put these numbers on
paper and make a plan for the future
Jake joins us up next in Raleigh North
Carolina Jake what's going
on hey how are you guys thank you so
much for taking my call absolutely how
can we
help uh so I had a question uh my
employer currently right now offers me
uh the ability
to uh I guess make my own selection of
percentage between a traditional and a
Roth and I guess I didn't know if I
should split up a percentage between the
both of them maybe do all 15% in one or
the other so I guess just curious on
your guys's opinion on it I'll tell you
what I do and if that's any consolation
I go full Roth me too I love the idea of
looking up at 60 and I've got 2 million
in a Roth account which means Uncle Sam
already took his share and I have 2
million taxfree dollars to use and so
the question is do you want to pay taxes
now or later and we can get into the
argument of will taxes be more later
versus less and what will your tax
bracket be I just don't want to worry
about that I know that's
right yeah okay so what do you what do
you think I should what do you think I
should do now I guess with what I have
been I have been using a traditional
okay should I roll that all over into
just pause leave the traditional where
it's at cuz if you roll it you're going
to have a tax burden to pay and you only
want to do that once you're in baby step
seven and you have no debt including a
mortgage and you can stomach that so I
would just pause what you're doing in
traditional and start in
Roth okay are you out of debt I'll do
that uh yes I am uh fully out of debt
excellent awesome and you got the
emergency fund you're investing
15% oh yeah currently I investing 10 I
can't afford to do the 15 so I'm I'm
going to make that uh election now what
what's keeping you from the other five
are you saving up for a
home um I guess it's just a personal
thing just not liking more money coming
out of my paycheck uh I do save a lot of
money I I have about $80,000 in a high
yield account currently MH and I just I
just kind of like just not seeing the
money go down I guess
in the stock market you mean like if
it's in an investment
account uh yeah and I don't really have
anything in Investments besides my
401k I just I only make that's the only
I guess investment that I do have and
then I just kind of keep everything in
cash until I eventually do buy home so
I'm kind of looking at that maybe the
next year or two is your 10% enough to
max out your
401K uh currently no no it is not I make
around
95,000 if I were you I would jump that
thing up to 15% I would get used to
working that muscle and get used to
living off 85 and you're going to be
real happy later on life you sure cuz if
you do go do a calculation on our
investment calculator what that extra 5%
will do CU you sound like a young guy
how old are you I'm 25 from 25 to 65 40
Years of that extra 5% and by the way
your income is going to go up you're
already making great money at 25 imagine
you're making 150 and you're maxing out
accounts it's going to blow your mind
how much money you're going to have and
I I know it's scary cuz you want to see
the money saved you don't want to see it
go up and down you know what I do don't
look at my I look at it once a year just
to go oh there it is you know what I'm
not going to lie George I I look at it a
lot more often but I can take it I just
like it I like I like riding the roller
coaster but if if you're skittish do
what I'm not saying you're skittish
George most people only look at their
401K when the Market's down I'm like
that's the worst time to look I know I
know so you're dude 25 years old you're
crushing it no debt I would bump it up
to 15 it's not going to change your
world dramatically but it will later on
so that's what I'm here for make a
decision today that future Jake will be
very grateful for this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
this is the ramsy show I'm George camel
joined by Jade warshaw this hour if you
enjoy show we would love it if you would
consider sharing the show cons
subscribing to the show leaving a review
wherever you're listening and sharing it
with friends it means the world to us we
have a very limited marketing budget
because you all are such great marketers
for us telling your friends about it you
know showing them the life change that
you've experienced that's one of the
best ways to get someone to listen to
the show you go you paid off all that
debt you're like yeah I've been
listening to the ramsy show got me
motivated heck I'm ready add it to the
repertoire there so we appreciate that
Chris joins us up next in Vancouver
British columia wow what a journey how
are we
Chris I'm good how about yourselves good
afternoon yeah Absolut good what's going
on with you how can we help I I need
some advice on something honorable and
meaningful to do for my children and
myself with an
inheritance okay tell us about
it okay it's been kind of a rough summer
uh my best friend of 40 years passed
away then my mom passed away a week
later and my stepfather just died
recently but
gosh yeah it's it's it's brought me back
to Jesus and it's brought you know
brought me deeper relationships with my
children so there's some positive things
out of all that tragedy and sadness wow
um what a great
attitude thank you yeah I'm I'm
definitely a half full glass kind of guy
you definitely are man I don't know how
you do it but we appreciate it it's
inspiring all right uh thank you thank
you so much for that so this is
generational money this is money that my
grandparents and I guess great parent
grandparents earn and they passed it on
to my mom's and she's passing it on to
me and it's a little over a half a
million Canadian dollars okay and uh I'm
60 years old I'm on disability I I work
part-time on Dairy Farm and I have two
young children they're eight and 10
years old cool so half a million dollars
your advice say again oh go ahead you go
ahead no I I I just love to know what
you guys think what are we going to do
with this
500 where is it sitting right
now it's uh the probate is just about
finished and then it will be transferred
to me and my sister so she's there's
about a million dollars plus transferred
and divided between the two of us okay
and you get 500 to do whatever you want
with that's correct do you need the
money uh you know I've been living like
a popper and a farmer for years no I
don't really need it so do you have do
you have your house paid
off no I do not I'm a renter and uh yeah
I mean that was something that was you
know top of mine is something like that
to pass on to the kids yeah do you have
any other debt a
house I have a little credit card debt
of a th000 bucks and that's it that's it
I think 500,000 might cover that so
that's a good start I love that so what
to do with the kids the property is the
thing to go for potentially I mean
Canada I know is wildly expensive every
caller from Canada is like a condo
starts at $2 million you know so I
understand that you know property may
not be the right next step right now I
think it's great long term because when
you're 80 and rent continues to go up
that worries me so I'd rather you get
into something even if that means hey
the kids aren't going to get anything
right now but they're going to get this
paid for house by the time I'm retired
and and gone from this world on the
what's your income working at a dairy
farm uh it's very small because I I take
care of the kids five days a week so
it's only about $1,400 a month because I
milk on the weekends um and Friday night
but that that's about it and the
disability is about 1,800 a month okay
and that covers
everything that's well it covers the
food and the rent and then you know the
bills and I've got about two bucks for
myself after all that yeah man you've
been living frugally you're not doesn't
sound like you have a lavish
lifestyle no not at all I mean you know
I I I I'm I'm a retired Chef as well so
I can get through the food thing easily
I can turn anything into a meal pretty
well I love this great skill to have so
yeah certainly what would it look like
if you started looking at real estate in
your area to see if there's something
that you could put a very sizable down
payment on if not pay 100% cash
for yeah I've been looking around and uh
you know because of my my farming
background I would like to have
something with a bit of land attached to
it and things as as you mentioned before
things are ridiculously expensive but it
seems rural
areas yeah I mean the Farmland that I'm
working on right now is $100,000 an acre
wow it's it's Insanity right wow and
everybody's talking bubble bubble bubble
but the bubble just gets bigger um so
I'm I would like to get something
without having a mortgage and I'm
thinking that it's is potentially a
buyer Market people have said there's a
place I've been looking at it for
700,000 and they said offer them four
these people have had this on the market
for five months yeah why not so I mean
yeah what's the worst that can happen
right I can super lowball and uh not get
it but at least I try yeah that's one
route to go cuz when you think about the
kids if we instill in them good money
principles help them avoid debt we help
them get their first car in cash we help
them go to school if that's their next
thing you know some college education
debt free beyond that they're going to
be okay they don't need a huge pile of
money at
16 and so I'd rather you set yourself up
well and then whatever's left from your
estate gets passed on to them and the
Legacy continues that way and there's
some fun things you can do now there's
only three things you can do with this
money you can give save and spend and I
would encourage you to do all three and
do that with them they're old enough
that they're gonna remember
this yeah well we we are giving I I do a
breakfast program at their school three
days a week and uh there's about 40 45
kids that come every morning and uh
there's a real need for it so we're kind
of in in the spirit of giving you know
that's that's when we're you know
expressing your faith absolutely as far
as I'm concerned you know not not not
talking from the pulpit but doing
something in the trenches that's good I
love that well there I would start to
divvy that up of course let this money
just sit I would put it in a high yield
savings account I don't know what the
for the Canadian version of that is I'm
sure there's something out there and
just park it for now and later on maybe
you invest some of it maybe you use it
as a down payment maybe we give some of
it maybe we spend some of it we take the
kids on a fun trip and go this is thanks
to the the wisdom and Legacy and good
money management of the ones that came
before
us hallelujah yeah I I think that's a
great idea that's what I wanted to do I
wanted to park it I didn't want to make
any rash decisions I don't have any kind
of crazy aspiration to have a Ferrari or
anything like that so well can I ask you
this some good advice I really
appreciate that well let me ask you one
more question do you have any money
saved for retirement and are you
currently putting away anything for
retirement that's a scary laugh Chris I
know it is ominous that's the laugh of a
man on the
edge yes yes I I I am a paycheck to
paycheck and it's through God's grace
that I I'm getting by every day no I do
not have any savings what's your
rent my rent rent is1 1836 which is a
screaming deal for a house in Canada
it's also over half of your income so
that's that's where I go I think real
estate might be the move just getting
something reasonable that you can pay
for in cash to remove that largest fixed
expense of your life you're going to
you're going to be able to breathe again
if you get rid of that rent and you'll
be able to have some money to set aside
into some sort of a retirement account
monthly it'll free up some margin for
you okay okay so that's good yeah
because I think there's my limit here is
a taxfree saving account is $120,000 if
that's what you mean by high yield but
I've only done just a really cursory
look at what I can do with the money
that's once again why I'm calling you
folks and yeah I think you're right
about being able to breathe all the the
chest pain would go away yeah even if
it's it doesn't have to be the dream
farm you may just be able to you know
help out on a farm nearby and you may
not be able to purchase the five acres
you always dreamed of but at least at
least getting rid of that expense is
going to let you retire with some
dignity and still have some money left
over to you know raise the kids mhm yeah
God bless you I really appreciate that
thank you thank you that's good
absolutely Georgia fham I would take
three months three to six months of that
I'd set it aside like you said in that
high yield just so he's got a cushion
there cuz he's living life on the
financial Edge then he all Tak one
emergency yeah but then he can take a
decent chunk of money and like you said
it sounds like he was talking about a
dream farm he can get something probably
for a little less pay cash for it he's
got margin now he can start putting
aside whatever he can I'd love for him
to get to 15% but man thanks for the
call Chris you're you're an inspiration
love that call that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books I'm George
camel she's Jade warshaw big thanks to
all the folks in the booth keeping the
show a flat and you America we need you
the show would be nothing without you
and we'll be back before you know
[Music]
it
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campell joined
by Jade warshaw this hour and we are
here for you America taking your calls
about life and money at
88255 225 let's kick it off with Barb in
Baltimore Barb what's going on hi George
and Jade thank you so much for taking my
call absolutely how can we help I well
I'm my question is that in my postc
career season of life do I have enough
assets given that I would not be saving
as much in future years that I could
afford to do a very limited remodel of
my kitchen oh the old postc career
kitchen remodel Barb this is exciting
what are you looking to do in the
kitchen well um it's it's Builder grade
stuff in there and I I guess counters
cabinets sink um I just had to replace
the refrigerator so that's already done
but it's a small kitchen it's not but
I'm thinking it would be maybe around
the range of between 20 and
25,000 okay but but I recognize it's not
a
necessity but it's not functioning all
the time real well and and I would like
to be able to have the kitchen in these
you know future years to be um I I don't
know that I'd ever have to sell the
house while I'm alive but but anyway I
just have not been able to make the
decision and and I wanted to talk to
Christians about it because I'm very I I
love stewardship I've always been good
at budgeting and um I have no debt um
but I don't know if I have enough money
and I've got all my numbers here you can
ask me anything whether I have enough to
be able to take that amount of money and
use it for something that's not I you
know like the roof I replace that sure
but this is just a Barb wants it and
that's okay to admit nothing wrong with
that how old are you Barb okay I am 69
I'm excited that in a few months I'm G
to turn 70 which seems that's exting
Milestone that's awesome and what kind
of uh Nest Egg do you have sitting
around okay here's here's 's my um um my
my house I have no debt and my house is
paid off my car I've never had credit
card debt I thought I'd tell you that
because I don't I don't ever I've never
done that um I have in my I guess you'd
call it deferred tax my what came from
my 403b that is now with an investment
company that's 200,000 okay and I don't
plan on I'm living on my Social Security
and a part-time job um and I can
actually live on my Social Security I
have a very simple budget and how much
is
that um my currently my Social Security
well this year total um that
I uh what does it get what does it pay
every month what's what's the check that
you receive okay um the 1991 okay and
that's enough for you to handle
everything even if you quit the
part-time job you'd be
okay yes what what's what led me to call
you today is that the the dear lady that
I've been taking care of part-time as
caregiver this year she just um injured
herself and it it's unlikely I'm going
to have that job for well unless she
recuperates totally she may need more
care than what I can give so I made him
back to for a while just living on my
Social Security which is fine I can do
that but um but that brought question
more to what did that job pay you when
you were doing the health well this year
this year I made about 9,000 from that
private pay okay um um so so this year
that you know and that that mostly went
into savings I mean I really um I except
for the big things like the roof or the
sure you know um so that's that's but I
do have some other savings you want me
to tell you the other numbers ma yes
ma'am I have a Fidelity account that my
investment guy said is he could that
this is actually the money that I put
away a long time ago for the kitchen
it's um it's now
37,000 okay um and and that yeah and
that's just in a brokerage account it is
invested it's not on the money market
side no it's well I don't know what you
call it but he said he says it's liquid
okay that he could give it to me at any
time okay so it's probably on the money
market side and not it's ready to be
invested but it's just sitting there you
know basically % interest okay great oh
well it does it does grow one point it
had $88,000 more and now it's got like
$3,000 more than my the principal I put
in was 33 so it's 4,000 more than that
right now what other accounts do you
have I have a $20,000 CD okay and then I
have in savings I have 30 well 30,000
there's an extra I keep all of my
non-monthly bills I keep those in that
savings account too and I take them out
put my checking when I pay my bills so
when you take out your bills what's left
28,000 no um 30,000 it's there's about
2,000 in there towards okay so you just
share that with your normal your social
security goes in there you pay your
bills and then that sits at 30 at 30,000
any other investment accounts well the
checking account goes um is where I pay
things from and that's where my my
social security goes into so total 200
um let's see there with
so about
287,000 um 200 um under 69 49
6970 about 20 270,000 if you count the
the retirement fund which I don't want
to that 200,000 is and what's your home
worth by the way you said it's paid for
well it's anywhere from this year
because prices went up people tell me it
is about 310,000 but normally it's 220
,000 so that's what I was counting as
the actual you know I'm I think it's
closer probably to 220 than it is to 310
it's a small townhouse that's a big leap
let's call it 250 okay so you've got
about a half million net worth yes and
you're wondering should I be spending
this 20 you have the money to do the
kitchen remodel for 25,000 but are you
wondering is this a a prudent and wise
financial decision based on my big
picture yes because I if I'm if I live
till you know God hasn't told me when
he's taking me home so if I if I if I
live till I'm 90 or older and you know
have and and there's going to be you
know my heating is going to go up my
everything is going to I have to all of
that savings has to go for
Necessities um especially you know if
I'm living on my Social Security and you
know that if if that all goes well I
won't need to take take from even if I
don't get a new caregiving part-time job
um so I I can't decide it myself I need
I need you to tell me if you think that
you not knowing how much I'm going to
live in the future and how much I will
be draining from all the savings well
just listening to you talk you're living
off your Social Security you haven't
touched any of your retirement which in
your case is great I do feel like you
have a lot of money that's kind of
sitting uninvested that I would make
sure is invested so that money is truly
working for you you've got 20,000 in a
CD 30,000 saved in another 30 thou
37,000 that we're not really sure where
that is so if I were you I'd make sure
at least 50,000 more of that money is
getting invested so it can earn a return
for you and then I'd have a professional
come out and I'd see what really is it
going to cost if I were you I'd probably
try to spend somewhere between 10 and
15,000 and do it on the L get get a few
bids and be reasonable but this sounds
like a good move if you're willing to
continue living frugal going
[Music]
mhm hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lump some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you are listening to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw this
hour give us a call at
aa825
5225 our question of the day is brought
to you by neighborly your hub for home
services for over 40 years years
neighborly has an exclusive network of
trained local service providers backed
by the neighborly Done Right promise so
if it's not done right neighborly we'll
make it right visit neighbor.com Ramsey
to learn more and here's the question of
the day brought to you by Jade thank you
it says today's question comes from Mark
in Arizona he says I was sadly laid off
earlier this month between my wife and I
we have around 54,000 worth of credit
card debt we are currently trying to
figure out the best way to handle this
debt while I search for a job
should we just pull our limited extra
leftover money and just slowly pay off
the cards one by one while neglecting
the minimum payments or would a debt
consolidation or debt settlement company
be better to handle this um you know if
I'm looking at this I think that what
I'm sensing is you guys are panicking
because it's like oh my gosh I just got
laid off we've got this debt now it's
like now we want to pay it off and
you're feeling the crunch um I would
call this a storm though and whenever
you're facing a storm you want to make
sure you're just battening down the
hatches and making sure that you're
getting out of the storm and getting
through that safely so I probably one of
your options here was should we just
pull all of our extra leftover money and
no I would not do that as a matter of
fact I would just kind of hold tight and
right now I would focus on making the
minimum payments right just satisfy
those minimums and then I would really
put all of your effort into finding
another job that's thing one we've got
to get income coming in so we're paying
Li uh minimum payments getting a job
coming in and then once you get the
security of a job coming in now we can
start reworking those baby steps and in
this case if you're on baby step two
yeah list those things out smallest to
largest and now that you feel how this
can negatively affect you hopefully that
feeds into your intensity to get this
paid off super fast right George
absolutely and you know debt
consolidation comes up a lot on the show
and we're not fans of it and there's a
good reason it's because it doesn't
actually change your world it doesn't
change the behavior that caused it all
it does is make you think you did
something by moving debt around now
there are situations where if you've got
you know 17% interest 22% interest on
this credit card and you can go down to
zero and you already have the gazelle
intensity yeah it can help and you'll
pay a little less less in interest but
the bigger thing it does is help you
feel like you're making progress on the
debt by knocking it out faster but if
you don't already have that kind of
gazelle intensity which many don't yeah
then what they do is they get
comfortable cuz they go well we're not
paying any interest on it so we'll just
I kind of like sometimes that there's
there's a higher interest rate that
makes you go gosh you see how much we're
paying in interest never again will I go
into debt that's why I call it versus a
shortcut like debt consolidation and
these debt settlement companies Jade
these drive me crazy oh they're the
worse they're borderline scams you pay
these people a giant pile of money and
what they do is they tell you okay stop
paying on your debt completely we'll
take it from here it tanks your your
credit score which we don't care about
credit scores but tanking it will hurt
you as you continue to live your
financial life on purpose and then they
try to settle the debt saving you money
maybe but a lot of times what happens is
you just them all this money and the
debt sits out there I just feel like
when it comes to those consolidation
places whatever they're offering to do
you can honestly do it for yourself yes
like you can get on there on the phone
and if you're trying to negotiate a
lower interest rate you can do that if
you want to negotiate a lower minimum
for the other ones while you pay a lot
on the the the the little one you can do
that yourself if you want to negotiate
something where you're taking a portion
of your paycheck and putting it towards
your debt you can do that matter of fact
we haven't ever budgeting app that can
help you do that you find all of your
margin and you put it towards your debt
so yeah I would almost never well I'm
going to go on out of limb and say never
do a debt consolidation simply because
honestly what they're offering you can
do yourself and you don't have to pay
somebody exactly look at that and
putting all of your separate debts into
one giant debt doesn't make it easier it
makes it harder because you don't feel
the progress you're not knocking out
payments along the way so I like to keep
it all separate to uh to feel the the
winds there so thank you for the
question mark but I would work on like
Jade said you need to have no
interruption of income go work do
anything you can right now in storm mode
and we'll get back to that debt as soon
as we get some stability love it all
right let's get to Zach in Lacrosse
Wisconsin Zach what's going
on hey guys um I'm wondering what you
think about liquidating some Roth IRA
contributions to fund the per the
purchase of some acreage adjacent to my
current property ooh Why are you buying
this land like why is this suddenly very
important to
you well so it just came up basically uh
my neighbor just has a plot of land that
he's owned for about 10 years and he
just said hey I'm you know within six
months or so I'm going to sell this
place do you guys want it and of course
we do you know it' be amazing to have a
100 acres or whatever
um so it did kind of come out of the
blue but it's certainly something that
we would like to have um just really for
recreation so we have some acreage of
our own and it bus up against it so
hunting and so how many acres do you
already
have 20 and what would this add to
it like how much are you looking to
purchase so this would add another
20 okay You' go from 20 to
40 yes and what's it going to
cost uh about
85 okay and how much do you have in
cash well I've got a little over 40 in a
brokerage account that I would use for
it we've got well over a six-month
emergency fund so we probably turn that
into more like a thre Monon so maybe
take 10 to 15 out of there um and then I
was thinking you know I I guess I have
access to somewhere around 35 in Roth
area contributions I mean ideally that
would be the last pool that you pull
from
um but what would it look like if you
bought 10 more acres for the 45 that you
can get your hands on instead of 20
acres and touching your
retirement I don't think I'm almost
positive our Township doesn't allow for
the acreage to be split up like that you
buy the whole thing or not do you have
any debt
currently we have $300,000 mortgage
otherwise we have no Consumer Debt and
what's your household
income
160 man this feels like a lot to take
on cuz I would tell you let's pay off
the house first before we go and get
more land more property I know you're
itching to get more acreage but uh
unplugging now for the listener's sake
let me make it clear that what you're
talking about here is not withdrawing
from a retirement account with taxes and
penalties you can take out the
contributions from a Roth IRA without
penalty I wouldn't do it because it
would hurt me too much to unplug all
that growth and future opportunity for
that money because you're you sound
young how old are
you uh 35 okay leaving that money in
there I would crunch the numbers because
it may help you you know step off that
ledge my friend and go uh that's going
to hurt too much later on if I leave if
I left this $335,000 to grow in this
account what would that turn into 20
years from now 30 years from now and how
much faster can I just save up and try
to pay cash for this land if I really
want it it still feels like doing too
much on top of your 300,000 mortgage to
then buy another right 85 Grand worth of
land we're talking 400 Grand here making
160 in today's world it it just feels
like you're biting off a lot and you may
not regret it later you may regret it I
don't know down the line you may call
back and say I shouldn't have bought
this land but if you're going to do this
deal I would pause and is there any
urgency is he going to give up this land
to someone else
tomorrow no there's he's he has told us
we have a few months and he will let us
know for sure before he lists it so he's
been very you get first nice about it
and he he wants to do a private sale he
wants it to be easy so there's an
incentive for him to sell it to
us should I I mean is the the price
versus like what the actual value might
be because I feel like he's giving me a
decent price should I be considering
that I this I mean because I'm I
wouldn't because at the end of the day
what really denotes whether or not you
should buy something is whether or not
you can actually afford it not whether
or not it's on sale whe not whether or
not it's a deal you either have the
money or you don't regardless if it's a
deal regardless if it's on sale so in
this case the only way that I would
consider doing this is if you were only
buying half the amount and you had the
cash to pay for it and then you still
got your mortgage there but to be honest
you really should should focus on your
mortgage first and put that same
intensity that you're looking to buy new
land into paying off the land and home
that you already have and that's just
keeping it real yeah I'd take money out
anything beyond that emergency fund I'm
throwing it at the house if you guys are
debt free let's just knock this thing
out so that when an opportunity does
strike you're ready for it that's right
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
I'm George camel she's Jade warshaw this
is the Ramsey show you can call us at
8825 5225 we'll chat about your life
your money and we'll give you our best
take on what we would do if we were in
your shoes Diana joins us in Los Angeles
Diana welcome to the Ramsey
Show hello hi hey what's going on I have
I have a question so I have co-signed a
car with my my mom she's 83 years old
and if she passes is the car going to be
mine well is the title in your
name Yes mine and hers as well as the
loan yes okay unless there's something
else dictated in her will and
wishes it's your
car okay I mean isn't it at your car
now um it's it is both of our names yes
uh I don't think she has a will but I am
um uh the power of attorney for my
mother okay is she still driving
so no she can't drive anymore so we
we're paying monthly payments on a car
that's just sitting
there I'm driving it I'm using it I take
her to and from you know appointment so
you don't have a personal
car this is the only car I have okay
what does it take to get her name off of
it just to make it
clean oh I don't know how to go about
that and if I can I don't know well you
would have to be able to afford the loan
on your own would you be able to afford
it um I don't know honestly that's a
good question what's the car worth where
do I um
23,000 and what do you owe on
it um
the payoff is 23 that's still the amount
okay and what's you're not sure what
it's actually worth if you sold it
private party yes I did the Kelly Blue
Book and it shows about 17 to 19 okay so
I'm like upside down about 4,000 yeah
somewhere there and what's your
income my income is about uh 6 to 6,500
Nets a month okay is this your own only
car or do you have another car that you
were driving before you signed up with
this one for with your
mom uh I have another car that has like
3,000 on it and uh my daughter's using
it how old's your daughter paying for it
um she's
29 what would it look like and what's
her financial situation real quick it
can she afford her own
car not at the moment
no here's what I'm getting to I would
love for everybody to have their own
cars like I would love for your 29
almost 30y old daughter to have her own
car that she pays for I would love for
you to then have your car back that you
bought and only owe $3,000 on it and
then I would like you to get rid of this
car that you got with your 83-year-old
mother who no longer
drives that's that's an ideal setting in
my mind because right now it's kind of a
little bit of a
spiderweb I thought about that honestly
but I'm kind of like I feel bad um
because she'll be left without a car and
she is working so I don't know but she's
working right does she have
kids no no kids okay she's a fully grown
woman who's got a job I don't think you
should feel bad about that at all I
think you should feel like wow I'm I
have confidence in my daughter that she
can make it in the real world and pay
cash for a car that she can afford with
her job true you know what I'm saying I
agree do you have any other
debt a lot of other debt yes and I have
been um listening to the show for a
while now and have made so many mistakes
and now I'm back again I'm following the
Ramsey solution way good and uh I've put
my debt together and I kind of have
numbers if you want to you know well I'm
wondering are you able to pay off this
car in a year or
two no I don't think so if you can't pay
it off in the next year or two I would
sell it and I would scrape up together
the money that you're underwat on that's
$4,000 scrape that up sell the car be
done with it and get you some get a
beater car for now until you can
upgrade what's the pay My worry is about
I had a beater car and I got rid of it
because they break down and I can't
afford to fix it so that's what made me
go in there and get the new car out
again how long is sorry I'm changing I'm
going in another Direction how long has
your daughter had the $3,000 car has she
had it for a long long time
uh just about a year now she's uh making
the payments and uh paying the insurance
so and is that in your
name yes yeah I look you got a lot of
Financial Risk on your shoulders right
now if it were me I would get that car
back I really would I'd be like hey I'm
glad that this has helped you out let's
get on a plan for you to get your own
car and let's set a timeline for this
because I'm trying to get my financial
house in order and i' like you said I've
made a lot of mistakes and honestly one
of the mistakes mes I made was getting
our you know getting your grandma a car
and then sliding my car over to you and
I've got to make this right daughter how
long can you how long will it take for
you to get a little bit of cash together
so you can buy a car in cash and so that
I can have my car back so that I can
sell Grandma's
car oh okay so that's the plan that I
would set in motion I'd set that plan in
motion today I'd call her up and say hey
let's get on a a three or four month
plan here
gotcha okay so give her a timeline like
to yeah give her some time I mean you're
not going to just snatch it out from
under her but I think I think it's good
for you to say hey I've made mistakes
and I'm trying to get my life in order
and maybe that will push her to do the
same because it sounds like she's got
some things to get in order and then in
the meantime what other debts do you
have I have about a
$10,000 uh credit card debt I have the
car obviously it's 23,000 I have a plot
that I just bought which is like
12,000 and I have um tax debt how much
is the tax
de00 um I would say 2700 plus 1,900
whatever that total is okay one one's a
tax from Utah and one is here in
California okay and what's your income
that you're bringing
in uh bring in net uh six six from 6,000
to six oh that's right you did say that
you did say that okay and what was the
plot for was this like a funeral
plot I'm sorry was this a funeral
plot yes the plot for me yes I bought it
and I'm making payments on that too
yikes okay well the Step Zero is to stop
going into debt and that's the hardest
step truthfully out of this whole plan
is just to stop the bleeding and go no
more debt is off the table if we can't
pay for it we're got to figure out
another way if that means public
transportation and getting on a bike
we're doing it but right now we've got
to have that Line in the Sand otherwise
we're going to continue down this path
and there's always going to be something
else that comes up there's always going
to be another reason to swipe the card
so I would cut up the cards number one
and stick to using your own money okay
all of them I already have and I paid
off one small debt I did trying to do
I'm on step number two excellent I just
have $1,000 and that's all I have the
plot you bought is that for you or were
you trying to help out your mom
again no it's for me my mom has hers
that we just paid off and you know it's
there so all right this one is mine okay
so let's put this IRS debt at the very
top of your list this trumps everything
in the dead snowball we've got to attack
this one with intensity and get this
monkey off our back get Uncle Sam out of
there then we can start focusing on the
smallest debt smallest to largest we're
going to increase our income we're going
to do what Jade said with this car and
get out from under this weird situation
where we found ourselves in and that's
going to give you some traction right
there you free up that car payment how
much is
that uh my car payment is
379 great oh yeah that's about 400 bucks
you can start throwing at the next
smallest debt and the next smallest debt
and you'll get there in no time this is
not a huge amount of debt comparatively
to your income yeah it's just confused
it's all over the place okay we just
haven't had traction but I love that
you're on the plan now you're ready to
do this thing yes I am and I have a goal
to be debt free and uh I just don't know
when I'm to get there I'm just very
overwhelmed right now write it down and
put it on your bathroom mirror to remind
yourself every single day and let us
give you every dollar because if you can
plug these numbers into every dollar it
won't be an unknown anymore you can use
the financial road map feature plug all
your numbers in and you can see exactly
when you'll be debt free exactly when
you'll have your 3 to 6 months of
savings and that is going to give you a
lot of peace of mind going forward and
you can sign up for our free every dooll
webinar we're doing this Friday I'll be
leading it everydollar.com sludge I'll
walk you through how to set it up and
hang on the line we'll gift that premium
version to you thank you so much for the
call this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by Jade warshaw
the number to call is 8825
5225 well Jade producer James uh
introduced a very interesting article to
us that delves in the world of politics
I'm not going to get political but it
also crosses over into our land of
personal finances so I thought I'd read
it to you and see what you think about
it yeah okay read it you ready for this
this is a Fox news headline claim that
speaker Johnson lives paycheck to
paycheck makes him relatable say
Defenders so here we go some Americans
rallied behind house Speaker Mike
Johnson on Wednesday after a report
nitpicked his personal finances and put
a harsh Spotlight on the possibility
that he lives p Che to paycheck so this
is speculation pure speculation but
here's Daily Beast published a report
that says does new Speaker of the House
Mike Johnson have a bank account
question mark it featured a subhead that
said he has never listed a bank account
on his financial disclosure and his
newest disclosure doesn't list a single
asset at all and apparently he has no
there's no record of him owning a single
stock no Investments at all that's crazy
it says this man is not on the grid it
says of course it's unlikely Johnson
doesn't actually have a bank account
what's more likely is Johnson lives
paycheck to paycheck so much so that he
doesn't have enough money in his bank
account to trigger the checking account
disclosure rules for members of Congress
aha what's crazy to me is like number
one broke equals relatability that's
just sad uh we need to change that and
that's basically why we relatable wow um
what I am thinking about so I just
Googled cuz I wasn't sure I Googled the
salary for speak of the house $223,500 a
year and he just got a raise here so he
got that to his credit yes which is like
that's a lot of money but I think
sometimes people think if you're in the
government you're automatically like
wealthy blah blah blah but there is that
stat George that says a third of
Americans who make $250,000 or more live
paycheck to paycheck which in my opinion
is really sad because at that point your
salary is up in the upper you know at
least 7% and if you're living paycheck
to paycheck it's just a testament that
your income doesn't denote that you are
good with money and no matter how much
money you make if you are a poor Steward
with your money or if you don't know how
how to handle your money well it will
escape you and you will be known what is
relatable as relatable or also broke
that's right and to be clear we have no
idea his financial situation he may be
fine uh but talking this is news trying
to drum up some drama around whatever
they can to get some clicks you know
that's the name of the game I think that
when here's this is just Jade's take I
think that the the more money you make
the slipperier the slope because when
you make $50,000 when you make 40 you
know $40,000 $60,000 you're just kind of
like right in there you know median
income I think is like 67,000 it's kind
of like this is you know this is
Americana I'm in my life you know I've
got my used vehicle you know you don't
have this stand that you have to prove
to the world but I think when you start
creeping up peeping and creeping on
100,000 and peeping and creeping on
200,000 people start to be like oh you
know I have to show like there's a
little bit of status that comes into
that where people feel like they have to
show a certain lifestyle and so it's
like suddenly your mortgage is a little
bit more and suddenly you're buying that
new Escalade because everybody else
around you has that and now all the
people around you are eating at more
expensive restaurants and you feel like
you've got to get onard Bo and not only
that but when you if you make the
decision like hey maybe I need to step
back and like get myself on track it
shows like you it shows when you're like
you know what I don't want to go to
Ruth's Chris I want to go to Chili's
like are you telling me that your
friends aren't going to notice that are
you telling me your friends aren't going
to notice when you go from driving a
brand new Escalade to a 2013 Tahoe you
know what I'm saying so it's almost like
you really have to get your mind right
when you're in that situation because
people if you decide to change people
will'll see the change it's not like you
know one of these things that you can
just do and keep it under wraps like
it's going to show and that's okay it
should show but I do think that it makes
it more difficult that's a good take
right there and there is a piece to this
you know we found in our millionaire
study teachers were the one of the top
careers for Millionaires and again
teachers aren't trying to flaunt
anything I mean they're just trying to
survive the next day with these kids and
so they're not driving around luxury
cars and you know he's probably got a
brownstone and DC and paying top dollar
it's an expensive lifestyle in the big
city with the big job with a big salary
and so it makes sense that they're
living paycheck to paycheck I mean you
just add up a few debt payments and all
of a sudden you got a $1,000 car payment
$4,000 mortgage yes you're trying to
keep up nice clothes eating out yes and
you're used you're used to that
lifestyle so the minute somebody's like
hey you're going to have to cut your
country club membership it's like you
know it's like hey by the way painful
you're not going to have a personal
trainer anymore like you know listen
real Speaker of the House Mike Johnson
if you are listening to the show we're
here to help uh you can contact us
privately let's give them every dollar
for free we'll be have we'll give you
everything we got man to help if you can
just start to leak some of these good
financial principles to Congress that
would be a GameChanger look I've got an
every dollar promo code with Speaker of
the House Mike Johnson's name on it
there we go but I hope none of this is
true I hope he lives a fine Financial
life and uh he just isn't you know
trading stocks yeah you know very
shadily like those Congress members who
know a little too much about what's
going on to be trading stocks I think uh
I'm for that getting shut down Jade
that's my that's my political take again
this is just George and Jade talking
this is speculation none of this is fact
but hey speaking of the government let's
shift to something very happy this is
exciting in honor of Veterans Day for
those that have served we're giving away
Financial Peace University to 10,000
veterans totally free right now through
Monday November 13th so FPU if you don't
know is the proven fastest way to beat
debt to build wealth it's helped nearly
10 million people and we love our
service members out there so if you're a
veteran you want to take FPU for free on
us go to ramseys solutions.com veterans
and fill out a very simple form and if
you guys could help us get the word out
I know every single one of us knows we
have a veteran in our life that we love
please share that link with them and
tell them to get it ramsy solutions.com
veterans is the way to get it thank you
so much for that there we go we ended on
a happy note we did budgeting is always
a happy note I love it all right we have
time for a quick call let's get to
shanana in Portland shanana what is
happening on Portland
Maine good afternoon guys thanks for
taking my call sure um I wanted to get
your take on a question that my
boyfriend and I have had for a little
while which is is getting married
financially beneficial for a couple that
owns a business together what is the
what does that have to do with
it it really is not we see marriage as a
contract we feel like we are committed
we've been together for eight years the
this sparked up when we told our
accountant that we wanted to start a
business together and he said I'm not a
marriage counselor but this would be
easier if you guys were married and well
not only easier but safer for both of
you
and I guess that's my question like why
would it be safer and what is your take
on there what the heart of the question
is strange cuz it's like well if there's
a financial benefit I guess we'll get
married that's just a weird way to go
about it and so while there are
Financial benefits I wouldn't just get
married because of the tax benefits
that's weird I would get married because
it's the right move for you guys and I
mean you've signed some business
documents together right which felt like
it we did which felt like we were
getting married when we were signing
though right I mean as far as risk goes
yes I if you called in here and you were
just like hey me and my boyfriend blah
blah blah blah blah we have this
business we have this house trust and
believe I'd be like y'all need to go
ahead and get married and my my attitude
behind that would be more for the the
safety and benefit of both of you I mean
you clearly love each other you clearly
want to do your life together so that in
my mind George goes without saying but
in this case if you're going to be in a
business together heaven forbid
something should go wrong with your
marriage
you want the safety of having a union
together so that when you do get a
divorce and this goes behind before a
judge there's complete fairness on both
of your sides otherwise if you don't
have that cover of marriage it's like
either one of you at any point could
just be like hey I'm out oh and I'm
taking this money oh and I'm doing this
and there's just not the same
protections
there okay I understand that makes not
that you would do that but do you see
what I'm saying you never know what the
future holds sh I hope you guys if
you're ready to get married which I
assume you are you know8 years together
you're running a business together take
the next step it's sounds like it's time
if you have a healthy relationship uh
you've already committed to business so
let's commit to each other in that big
way excited for you guys I hope the
business goes very well and the you know
impending marriage goes well that puts
this hour of the Ramy show in the books
my thanks to Jade warshaw my co-host all
the folks in the booth and you America
will be back before you know
it
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camell joined by Jade warshaw and
we are taking your calls this hour at
8825 5225 you give us a call and we will
give you our opinion that's how the show
Works um I would call it advice but some
people may disagree Jade I think your
advice is always spoton I would say the
same about you George I try my best you
know I flub some I'm I'm not infallible
Nei none of us are look we make we try
all right Jonathan is in Baltimore let's
give it a go Jonathan how's it going
pretty good how you guys doing pretty
well how can we help so so I have a
question so we're my wife and I are
currently on baby step two um we got
through baby step pretty one pretty
quick I was able to do a side
job pretty much after that first lesson
within a week I had that amazing that's
great um so we're going through and I
know it says to stop your 401k
contributions to help pay off your
debt now my question is I get
a a quarter percent match up to
4% do I stop getting that free money and
and stop putting in for now I also have
a 401k loar that I'm paying on
but yeah um the answer the answer is yes
to your question we would tell you to
stop that match and stop contributing
but it's temporary and right I look I
get it it's free money the the math nerd
and everybody goes berserk when we say
that but the point here is you're going
to free up all of your income at that
point and what you need right now is
income in order to pay off your debt
right that's the whole point baby step
two it's laser focus we're paying off
this debt as quickly as possible and
here's the thing most people are out of
debt in two years or less and then at
the end of that not only after you've
built up your savings not only are you
going to be investing 4% with a match
but you're going to add 11% to it and
you're going to do that for the rest of
your working job now if you're telling
me you're not going to make up what you
lost in 2 years or less at that point do
what I'm saying we're playing a long
game here right right right no I I I'm
pretty sure that I would um and again I
don't want to be is you know I want to
be on board
um so you know I had a couple people say
well it's free money you know
but you know I mean luckily my wife and
I well not including our house we're
probably about $30,000 in debt and that
includes an automobile that's about
25,000 what's your household
income um I would say combined roughly
is probably 160 wait a
second you got $30,000 in debt and you
make 160 you're going to be out in like
three month you're GNA be out so fast so
this is a non this is a non-point
Point okay if you actually did the math
on what you'd be losing and also the
interest you're paying on the debt if
you hang on to it long with less going
at the principal it's negligible but
what will help is the fiery intensity
you feel when you go down 0% and you
clearly love investing and when you go
to 0% you're going to be like I want to
get back to investing so badly I'm going
to take on three jobs to get out of this
debt faster in two months instead of
three and that's the kind of fire that
will carry on and will allow you to hit
all of your financial goals and like
Jade said you're going to quadruple your
investing yeah I have six months from
now now you quadruple that after the 3
to six months uh-huh but you're going to
do all of that you're going to do all of
that in the next 10 months right you're
going to pay off this 30,000 and then
you're going to pay uh save up 3 to six
months uh whether you do three or six
months is determinable on you know what
your situation is with your income sure
how old are you sure uh I'm 46 okay so
imagine 47 year old Jonathan who's
investing 15% of
$160,000 household income which is
incredible and then do the math 20 years
from 47 to 67 what that turns into and
you'll see why we want to light this
fire under you to stop this measly 4%
temporarily to go way up to 15% and then
soon enough in that time you're also
going to pay off the house following
this plan which means you're going to
invest even more than that in your
greatest wealth building years when you
have the highest income and catchup
contributions after you hit 50 you're
going to be crushing it mhm so I would I
would ignore your friend saying dude
you're an idiot if you don't take the
free money cuz guess what they're
probably broke man yeah and they I was
about to look I was about I to assume
they're idiots we don't know that but
you they could be very wise billionaires
for I don't know your friends that's
right they're probably great people but
the point is I liked what George said
and I think it's so true when you go
through this process you do need to feel
a little bit of that ouchy like that
sting like duh why did I do that yeah
you know that's the lesson learner right
there I started I started for 1K when I
was much younger but
then um through whatever reasons you
know it got emptied out and I restarted
a few years ago and I've been watching
that number now granted it hasn't been
growing like it was before but and
that's it is an Aly to me because yeah
you know as I'm getting older I'm like I
want to be able to retire at a
reasonable age you know and so it is a
little bit of an ouchie to me well
Jonathan you just taught the lesson for
us because here's what happens when you
start investing before you've paid off
your debt and before you have an
emergency fund what happens is your
Investments your retirement Investments
become your emergency fund it becomes a
thing that you dip into when you need a
little bit of extra cash and like you
said you start a Roth you take the money
out you start your 401k you take a 401k
loan and that's why we teach it this way
because that way you're on you're on the
firmest Financial footing that you can
possibly be on you've got no debt right
so the money that comes in is yours then
you've got this money set aside that's
totally liquid it's 3 to 6 months of
expenses in case you do fall on Hard
Times where it's like okay look I have
to get a new refrigerator and suddenly
you can just pull it from that money as
opposed to having to dip into your 401k
where you're then laiden with fees and
penalties does that make sense so that's
that's the thinking behind all of this
and I love that you called in because
you're kind of a a prime pupil for this
because I think I heard you say that you
do do have a 401k loan out already right
yeah we we bought our house um last
December and we had two dogs and it
didn't have it didn't have a fence so I
borrowed out of my 401 so that I could
put the fence up to protect the dogs I'm
sure probably could have done it myself
but still
um so I am paying on that so I still
have to I mean they'll the duct that
from my you know it's a bi-weekly
payment that I think it's like 78 bucks
or something like that sure but doesn't
that suck to here's the thing you just
told us you're so sad missing out on the
free money while you just robbed your
401k and unplugged the
growth you know it's part of the and I
didn't realize this and I'm you know we
just we started this small group here at
our house we're hosting it and um you
know if I had known a year ago that it
said don't borrow from your 401 you know
because it's it's a I don't want to say
it's a a lie but borrow from yourself
and you pay yourself back interest and
everything but in reality that money
isn't there so it can't really grow
exactly well here's the thing Jonathan
it's all it's all shortcuts and if it's
a shortcut you got to run far away man
cuz it's going to end up with you being
broke regretting it so I have full faith
in you we love you man we're cheering
you on on this debt-free
[Music]
journey
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshock hey
if you are already starting to think
about the holiday season and shopping
for the love the loved ones in your life
check out our $112 sale that's a killer
deal on some of our bestselling books
like The Total Money Makeover baby steps
millionaires own your past change your
future just 12 bucks each and when you
go to ramsy solutions.com store you're
going to see some fun new things too
including my brand new book Breaking
Free from broke which is now on pre-sale
our friend Rachel Cruz has an awesome
new kids book called I'm glad for what I
have there's the 2024 ramsy gold planner
featuring our very own Jade warshaw in
there and so you can go check all of
that out at ramsy solutions.com store
and while you're there we've got the
Ramsey Christmas Cash giveaway you could
win up to five grand and enter daily for
more chances to win so lots of fun
things to do on that website but you got
to go to make it happen Ramy
solutions.com
sstore Courtney joins us in Indianapolis
Courtney welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for having me yeah
how can we
help so I am wondering what I should do
with my apartment lease renewal when I
could potentially be getting married
next year o potentially this is a
variable here so we know it's happening
are you engaged well no not yet but I'm
not completely delusional uh my
boyfriend has put a deposit down on a
ring that I'm aware of and then he also
asked for my opinion on when he should
meet with my father to ask for his
approval promising this is promising I
was about to say I was about to be like
Courtney you're thirsty but he's not
exactly stealth mode here so this is
probably happening like by Christmas
what do you
think probably but then the the wedding
could be who knows when a year from now
two years from now hopefully sooner
right we my right my boyfriend and I
have discussed sometime next summer
maybe even in June um but my lease Ral
is up within the next month and I need
to make a decision within the next two
weeks and there is some variable between
which or how long I want to resign my
lease for does he does your boy or your
soon to be fiance does he own a home or
does he also have a lease he owns his
home I see so the plan obviously would
be then to move into his home when you
get married correct I see I see what
would what would look like if you tried
to sign a halfe
lease so they would allow me to do a
six-month lease but it is $300 over my
current amount um I each month okay with
yes each month so they are hiking at my
rates quite a
bit and I don't right I don't
necessarily plan on moving per se and it
does seem like the six month would be
the best option but I would also
probably have to live here for slightly
longer than those six months um and who
knows what the options and costs are
going to be if I have to sign next year
and I do have a friend who said that I
could live with her during the meantime
if I needed to get out of my apartment
before officially getting married but
there are just a lot of variables at
play here so if I'm you I don't want to
jump the gun right but it sounds like
you guys are having real conversations
about when you will be married so it
doesn't it doesn't feel like it would be
out of bounds for you guys to sit down
and go okay here's what we're really up
against if we get married we're moving
into your apartment and or into your
house and I've got this apartment if I
do this six-month thing it's going to
cost me $300 more every month for 6
months I really don't want to live with
my friend it sounds like you guys have
to do some actual like schedule planning
on this because if he's waiting do we
know if he's waiting because he just
wants to do a really romantic Christmas
Proposal is he waiting cuz he's still
saving up money for the ring like I feel
like there's more I feel like there's
more conversations to be had in order to
really inform this decision and make the
best
decision okay that's fair is that fair I
mean otherwise I would just say hey just
talk to your apartment complex and see
if you can do a month-to-month thing let
them know that at least you're going to
need six months but if it needs to be
seven or eight will they be willing to
do that tell them the situation I mean
you could definitely start there but I'm
the type like I want to know like I get
it like engagements you do want there to
be this element of surprise like I get
it I've watched the Hallmark movies but
at the end of the day it is real life
and it's like no there's real money on
the line here $300 a month yeah that's
1,00 bucks for six months Courtney so
what would it cost to break the lease
let's say you did 12 month and then
randomly you had to dip out what would
that cost you I'm guessing more so yes
and it's not super clear within the
lease agreement it's very broad when it
comes to it said or they say it would
cost two months of rent but it's not my
rent it would be Market rent at the time
and so that change any given that means
they can screw you what it means right
I'm not doing that no so we're not doing
that I want to give your best shot and
go hey if I do an eight month and cut
early or six month and then go month to
month and I did this with my apartment
and if you just get to know the people
at the front be real friendly with them
to where they go listen you know I just
got engaged it's very exciting here's
what we're kind of planning for a
wedding would you guys work with me and
just give me the same rate if I went
month to month it's probably going to be
just a month or two I'll give you a
60-day notice I'll even help you try to
find a new tenant all kinds of things
you can even get referral bonuses hey
what if I get another renter and you
give me 500 bucks for every renter I get
there's all kinds of things you can work
out with the apartment
complex but be firm and kind and real
friendly thank you so much Courtney good
luck on the impending engagement I'm
excited to dip out on that one she
dipped she was so excited she was like
I'm going to go right now all right
let's get to JB in Memphis what's going
on
JB uh hey uh so it's a pretty weird
question I've got about
$15,000 saved up right now okay and I've
got about $10,000 left on my uh car
payment uhhuh but my grandmother left me
her house and she passed away not too
long ago so now I'm kind of stuck on the
point where do I either want to renovate
her home for me to move in after I
graduate college or do I want to go on
and pay off my vehicle I'm paying off
the car today the renovations are I mean
where are you living
now uh in my parents home how long can
you live
there I mean there's not really a set
time I guess until I graduate college
okay but she left this house to you
specifically yes sir
100% yes sir and you want to keep it and
live there yes sir yes sir it's a four
bedroom okay so my plan would be I'm
going to pay off all my debt is it just
the car loan yes sir so that's gone
tomorrow and you still have five grand
left and that's going to start your
fully funded emergency fund so let's get
3 to six months of expenses then we can
begin figuring out what's it going to
cost to renovate grandma's house and how
do I cash flow that and then step into
that with a lot of peace and a bunch of
cash in the bank okay are you working
already are you going to school uh yes
I'm going to school online and working
fulltime good what do you do fulltime
uh around $50,000 a year 15,000 a year
you said 50 50 50 doing what yeah what
are you doing um I'm working for the
city of Oxford Mississippi fantastic
great and is that the long-term game
plan uh no sir I want to go to school to
be an educator and hopefully Pastor a
local church okay wonderful so we got a
lot of goals ahead of us man yes sir I
like it so is your goal ultimately are
you planning on fixing up this house and
getting roommates that'll pay rent with
you or what's the goal four bedrooms is
a
lot I've been dating a girl for the past
four years so hopefully proposing in the
next year I've already bought a ring
okay really sit down and taking the time
with her
parents love it uh and then you're like
a fully grown adult at 18 I'm impressed
man look I never I Jade warshan never
could knows what he wants yeah I love it
Grandma set you up that's great I I'm
happy for you JB yeah so I I think we
work on a game plan even if it means if
you're going to move out of the house
and rent for a little while that's okay
to get some footing under you and get
some Independence while you save up and
renovate this house or if it's ready to
live in and you renovate it as you move
but do it at the speed of cash that's
fine but I would pay off my car first
and have a fully funded emergency fund
before I stepped into this home
ownership
Journey okay all right thank you it
sounds amazing that's hey that's the
best we've gotten today Jade is that it
sounds amazing that's what we aim for we
rarely hit it so thank you JB we hit the
mark on that one happy for you man
that's a pretty cool thing cool Legacy
for Grandma to leave that's the kind of
Grandpa I want to be I know right we
didn't even ask what the house was worth
who knows a billion dollars maybe could
be who knows if it's in uh Memphis or
Oxford could be a pretty penny over
there this is the ramsy show give us a
call 8825 5225 we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back this is the Ramy show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw the
number to call is 8825
5225 Kayla joins us just up the road
here in Nashville Tennessee Kayla
welcome to the
show hi yes I am had a question um we
are recently we just got out of a
Chapter 13 bankruptcy and are completely
debt-free but just kind of unsure where
to go from here when was the
bankruptcy um it was two years ago we
ended up selling our house and um paid
everything off and then um we have about
$25,000 that came back to us after
everything was paid off wow wow that's
intense how are you feeling after all of
that relief um but but also I obviously
we got into that situation because we
were not making great financial
decisions so I don't want to go back
there um so just trying to we haven't
touched a dime just kind of sitting
where we're at and um unsure kind of
where to go from here can I ask a
question it's a little bit of a past
question but when you filed for
bankruptcy what sort of debt was it like
was it medical things that you just felt
like you couldn't avoid or was this hey
we were just racking up credit card debt
we weren't paying attention to our money
can you kind of walk us through what led
to that what sort of Hab it was mostly
um just being honest not paying
attention to our money um we became
parents very quickly um and adopted
eight children at pretty much all at one
time wow rocked our world a little bit
eight children so we needed a bigger car
and just you know pause Kayla did you
say you adopted eight children people
yes holy moly at the same time
yes she just sped past that like it was
no thing my goodness wow
okay um so we just kind you know life
kind of you know got the best of us and
just trying to figure out you know how
to budget with this many and we're very
confident in that now um not struggling
whatsoever we have a nice income um what
is the
income um we make about 240,000 a year
comb combined so you and your husband
both work is it pretty split down the
middle of what you both bring in or is
one of you a a major bread winner um he
would be the major he's right about
200,000 and I have a business that I um
have taken a step back from however it's
fully functioning um so I stay home with
the children we have that okay that's
what I was getting at I didn't know if
one of you stayed home with the kids
okay very cool so you've got this great
income you've got 25,000 that you've got
sitting there is that enough to call
three months of
income um no that's about two months at
this point that's about two months okay
and when I say income I mean um when we
talk about three to six months of
expenses for your savings that's your
basic budget it's not all the bells and
whistles it's like hey this is just what
we need to keep the clock ticking
right okay call closer to three then
yeah we're probably closer to three okay
so for the next few paychecks we use
that to bolster that emergency fund
maybe you got eight kids I it may need
to be 35 or 40 I may have 6 months cuz I
would one of those kids has a health
emergency and boom there's a bill so
figure out what that number is start
looking at are you guys doing a monthly
budget since
bankruptcy um we yes but no um I feel
like we have um and this is kind of a
scary part is we have we don't have that
bankruptcy payment any longer which was
very large um so I don't want to go back
to using that I obviously want to put it
towards something so that's kind of
we're going to help you get on a budget
we're going to gift you a year of our
every budget with all the premium
features it's going to connect to your
bank it's going to show you a financial
road map it's going to help you with
Paycheck planning to make sure all of
your bills are behind the paychecks and
not in front of them so you'll get that
and then you can sign up for my
budgeting webinar I'm doing this Friday
everydollar.com budgeting and it's an
hourlong webinar where I show you how to
set up your every dollar budget how to
create margin that's your next step we
got to start paying attention to our
money because what got us into that
bankruptcy was not paying attention yes
correct so that's the first step the
second step is make sure you have your
four walls covered so that's food
utility shelter Transportation you guys
have that
covered yes we're not going back into
debt ever again for anything for any
reason agreed do you both agree yes we
agree have you cut up all credit cards
we're renting right now that's where
we're at so we have no credit cards we
are renting we would eventually like to
purchase a home
obviously that's me your next step after
you have this emergency fund we start to
get dreaming again about what our new
future looks like with a clean slate we
go hey we made mistakes been there done
that not doing it again we're going to
buy a house the right way and you know
what that means it's going to take a
long time it's probably going to take
you know three four five years to get
that down payment making 240 if you can
live off 60 70 80 90 you can start
shoveling away money into a savings
account and buy if you're living off
even if living off a hundred with them
if they can take 140 a year that's
you're going to be in a really good spot
but that's where the budget's going to
be so helpful because it's going to show
you how much margin you should and could
have if you follow the budget
okay and with no debt payments you're
going to get there in no time so does
that help you at all yes I just need
some direction we I don't I just am so
afraid of getting back into that place
and we've done a really good job of
maintaining so I would like to continue
with that but in a more positive way
well I think you're I mean I think by
calling in I think you've made the right
choice and it sounds like you're open to
doing what it takes to for sure not
repeat the past and really get on a plan
like George said I I love it have you
guys been through financial p University
we have not so I'm very new listener um
I'm very intrigued but um just got my
husband on board so we are ready to try
all the things okay well hang on the
line I'm also going to gift you
Financial Peace University this is going
to be a game changer but you and your
husband need to go through it together
this is not a Kayla goes through this on
her own go through this together as a
family use the every dooll budget and
call us back if you have any questions I
hope to see a Beautiful Redemption story
out of this I love that out of the ashes
absolutely but I get you know you're I
would imagine I've never walked through
bankrupt ruptcy but I could imagine the
biggest fear would be repeating the past
especially if you're not able to
pinpoint exactly what set the dominoes
in motion it's like all right what was
it was it this health scare was it but
in her case it was like we just didn't
pay attention yeah which is a very
classic
scenario all right let's go to Daniel in
Omaha Daniel how can we help
today hey guys thanks for taking the
call yeah what's going
on yeah so I have uh I guess I kind of
call myself a lurker I've kind of always
listen to Dave Ramsey and never really
actually practiced it until recently I
had a uh recent life change um a few
months ago um finalized a divorce we
have a two-year-old daughter so I guess
kind of um part of that process I guess
while I'm now on baby step two um is
I've been thinking about kind of getting
life insurance that way if something
were to happen to me yes um things are
are you know it's they're set up for her
in the future and obviously yes got to
have some ownership shares in my
business so I've got a trust already set
up so I guess there's no is it should I
wait until I'm paid off all debt or life
insurance something I should consider
now uh Daniel I love that you're asking
this question because by you calling in
you're going to help a whole bunch of
folks um George I think a lot of times
when we talk about insurances people
think it's like oh yeah after I after I
pay off my de I have a good financial
position after I get yeah then I'll get
my insurances in place and it's
absolutely not that as soon as you find
out about life insurance as soon as you
find out about these things we want you
putting them in place because the fact
is you don't know what the future holds
and the whole purpose of something like
life insurance is to replace income for
people who depend on it and in this case
it would be your daughter um and even if
you don't have kids it's important to
have life insurance because something
somebody and someone's got to cover the
cost if you were to leave this earth and
so having life insurance make sure makes
sure that that's the case so I certainly
uh would get set up with life insurance
I'd call Xander today yeah and Daniel
make sure you're getting term life
insurance don't fall for stuff you saw
on social media about whole life you
want term life insurance 10 to 12 times
your annual income a 15 or 20 year term
should do for you and that will set her
up for the future and give you peace of
mind as
well awesome real it's real cost
effective as well so don't let that
spook you expensive whole life insurance
is crazy expensive in a giant ripoff
because you're giving the insurance
agent a lot of commissions up front
that's right to cover this um with a
weak savings account attached to it so
term life is the way to go and our
friends at Xander that's who I'm covered
through they've covered millions of our
fans they will take good care of you
guys you can reach out to them through
ramsy solutions.com and uh click on our
trusted Pros there and I use them for
all kinds of insurance auto homeowners
they shop uh the top companies and
they're independent so you're not stuck
with your your bro from you know your
college buddy who works for the bigname
insurance company they'll find you great
coverage at a great price and it is
worth it I sleep better at night knowing
uh Whitney will be just fine if
something should happen to me sometimes
I you know I sleep with one eye open
look I know that's right Xander got that
stuff under a lock and key sleeping with
one eye open well I'm sorry you're going
through this Daniel but you're you're
taking the right next steps man this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw our
scripture of the Day 2 Timothy 1:7 For
God gave us a spirit not of fear but of
power and love and
self-control Thomas Stanley said
millionaires are risk-takers and they
don't become millionaires until they're
40 or 50 it's a slower process than a
lot of people think ain't that the truth
it's the tortoise versus the hair wealth
is
patience all right let's get to the
phones Michaela joins us up next in
Little Rock Michaela what's going
on hi there um thanks for for taking my
call um so I'm a teacher and the way
that our state works we contribute 7% of
each check and then our employer
contributes so much and it goes into
this massive State account and then when
we retire there's a formula of um your
contributed um whether we were certified
or not basically that gives us that
formula um I am just trying to figure
out because I'm only contributing 7%
where should I be putting that other
8% okay so you're not allowed to
contribute more than
that correct okay it's not an account
like like if I die I have beneficiaries
but it's not like oh it's just gaining
great interest not that kind of account
it's sort of like this weird pension
situation where you don't really have
control over it it's not great
Investments but it is what it is and
you're forced to do it yes correct and
then um if my calculations are right
I'll end up with between 50 and 60% of
my salary upon retirement okay and
obviously not great for a teacher salary
sure so what are the other options is
what you're asking to get the other 8%
invested right like should I contribute
that I my have my husband contribute
additional to his should I do my own
what's your household income best um
around 100,000 gross okay so we know we
need to be investing $155,000 a year
total by the end of the year and so one
place you can go is a Roth IRA it sounds
like you're eligible for that M okay and
that would be 15% just for me not for my
husband as well that's what I I'm sorry
I'm following I'm following now I'm so
sorry it's the end of a day I that's
okay that's what I wanted to get to I
want to make sure I want to make sure
you understand it's 15% total not just
okay so if you invest 15% of your salary
he invests 15% of his salary it will
amount to 15% of house hold salary M yes
yes long day teaching clearly totally
get it does he have anything associated
with his job a 401k of any type he um is
contributing 9% to a Ross with a 6%
employer match right now okay and is he
is it possible for him to
get to mat to is it Poss gosh it's the
end of the day for me can he make up the
difference and it all go to his Roth
401k um I think that will put him above
the limit for that um he can contribute
to a
403b what's his
income um we're both right around 50
okay and you're saying he has a Roth IRA
that he contributes to or 4K corre he
has a Roth that he contributes to but he
also has the ability to contribute to a
43d is he a teacher as well he is a
pastor okay okay I get it I get it okay
so yes so we want to make sure that the
match doesn't count in the 15% equation
that's icing on the cake so the easiest
way to think through this continue I'm
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt there
we're we're finishing up paying off debt
and so we're trying to look ahead and so
we're we're super close should be by the
end of the year Michaela this changes
the whole the whole doughnut here we we
we're talking about sprinkles we need to
pull it back pull it back come on George
so let's pay off all let's pause and
we're going to pay off the debt faster
if we go down to 0% temporar now it
sounds like you can't go down to 0% with
your situation I can't okay correct so
you're stuck doing that but he can stop
contributing the 9% MH of 50k which is
going to free up some money to throw at
the debt he'll be back to it in no time
in fact when he's back I want him
investing 15% so the simple way to think
through this once you have no debt and a
fully funded emergency fund of 3 to six
months of
expenses and here's the strategy you
need to Rattle off to him match beats
Roth beats traditional so if either of
you have a match that's where we want to
start investing up to the match okay
beyond that let's go to all the Roth
options that we can and Max those out if
we're still not at 15% then we can go to
traditional
accounts okay and so that might be for
him the 403b if he doesn't have a Roth
option um or your can you contribute
more to your school situation if
necessary sounds like you won't get not
mine is just what I'm doing so I should
do something either add tack onto his or
something separate well once you both
max out a Ira for the year you're
probably going to be right there okay so
I wouldn't worry too much about that um
but that's the simplest way to approach
it match beats Roth beats
traditional okay perfect absolutely good
luck on the debt payoff and getting back
to investing it sounds like you're
excited about it God bless our teachers
I know right all right I think we got
one more in US Jade let's do it Joe is
waiting in San Antonio Joe welcome to
the show what's Happening guys thank you
so much taking my call I love your show
you guys are incredible oh thank you
we're we're honored to have you how can
we help today I think this is a
no-brainer but I'm still going to ask
because I'm old and semi scile and I
don't want to make a mistake well you
know you're self-aware enough that tells
me you're still here with
us I just don't want to make a mistake
at my age I'm 69 years old my wife and I
are both retired we live off of Social
Security uh we have no debt at all my
house is worth probably 800,000 mhm
uh we have no credit cards no car
payments we're dead free right right do
you have any retirement 10 uh no that's
all we love live off is a social
security and how much is that every
month that's like uh 3,500 a month okay
3500 a month no Nest Egg got it well
there's a nest egg but well how much is
it I don't touch it uh about 100,000
okay okay and what's the question so so
what I want to do I have the opportunity
I live on two acres I have a big shop in
the back that I'm not using all and I
was thinking of converting that into
a what do you call it I can't think
little apartment can't think of the name
right now anyway so just adding on about
taking out a oh I'm sorry what that
again you're just adding on an extra
room yeah but it's not a part of my
house it's on my property but it's on my
shop in the back of the property okay or
or to it one or the other
approximately 600 to 1,000 sare feet I
haven't really decided okay but I want
to know since I don't want to test touch
that Nest Egg should I take a first lean
loan out on my mar no way man why would
you do
that because I can get a ride off I can
use go no no Joe you know who says I'm
going to do it for the write off broke
people who don't understand how taxes
work you're going to put your home at
risk go into debt after being completely
out of debt at 70 years old for a write
off you you don't need it how much is it
gonna cost I call how much is it gonna
cost get my brain straight what's the
addition gonna
cost what's that what's the addition
going to cost you uh roughly between 50
to 60,000 and what's it going to do for
you yeah what's the purpose well they'll
bring in roughly an extra income um
anywhere between 12 to, 1500 a month how
do you know someone's going to pay
$1,500 a month for a 600 foot spot on a
farm pretty pretty proven by
who uh it's gonna happen I'm not worried
about
that Joe but think about this the ROI in
this thing let's say $1,200 a month 12
months a year let's say That's All Pure
net profit you never have in a single
expense which is a lie that's 14 Grand a
year so even then it's going to take
years to Roi on this 60 Grand purchase
uhhuh
and you don't need it because you've
been saying you've been living off your
social social security just fine yeah
yeah and I think it's going to cost more
than that to get this thing up and
running I do too it may it just me I
mean Plumbing it may take around
electricity that's what I'm saying HVAC
but yeah exactly no i' I already done
all the figures and it's it can get up
there I mean if you had a way if you had
such a big big equity in my house that's
the only way I can probably recapture
some of the equity I'm not going to lose
the house because I I've already done
the math kind of uh $50,000 is 577 a
month for 12 years here's the thing I'm
not really sure what you need the extra
$1,200 a month for unless he was going
to take that money and invest it and
that was but I I think we're getting a
little star I Joe I'd back up I think
the reason you called was because you
knew deep down your heart this was
probably a bad decision and we were here
to validate that and now we're the Bad
Guys for ruining Joe's dream no we're
the good guys for for keeping him in his
right mind that's the show hey that puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give
[Music]
generously
yeah